listen just being here tonight being
with everyone it feels a little like the
community is is starting to creep back
together you think yeah absolutely man
i'm glad we were able to do this in
person and uh
this is this is the cool one man the
sags you know because you're best actors
representing each other so and every and
the other actor said good on you all
best ensemble
yeah it feels really nice really
grateful to be here and to be a part of
this organization and and have been
nominated by my peers
and it's your first time what does that
feel like your first time nominating i'm
not gonna lie i'm a little nervous this
is a lot there's a lot going on right
now
so what's gonna happen to you and kelsey
in
coming up i never know i kind of like it
that way but uh even if i didn't i don't
think taylor would tell me what was
happening and you wouldn't tell me no
and well i mean i literally don't know
i'm on the ride like everybody else we
get the scripts as they come in and as
we shoot and so yeah i have no idea what
is it about this show because we i mean
you know this show has has really kind
of grasped on to the audience in a way
that we haven't seen in a long time i
mean people are fanatical about
yellowstone yeah and that's i mean it
feels nice you know we work really hard
on it we love it we wanted it to be a
hit and you know this past season from
in between season three and four it
really made a huge jump as far as
the amount of people it's reaching yeah
you know it's great i love it i love it
there's becoming a yellowstone universe
we got 1883 we're about to have 1932.
so can you tell us anything about season
five are you guys shooting yet no we
haven't shot season five and i i
literally know nothing about it no but i
think we start in the middle of may okay
yeah okay
i wish i had more info for you
you'll be in here you're gonna have a
little fifty shades uh reuniting tonight
with jamie dortmund is here he's gonna
be here and he's nominated as well
when's the last time you guys saw each
other probably on set yeah filming the
film yeah i i haven't seen him a long
time but he's a great guy i can't wait
to see him yeah i love that so i love
when they open the show and you always
have actors talking about you know when
they got their sag cards and those are
always such great stories so i would ask
you when you got your sag card before i
let you go i was taft heartlead on my
first movie but
funny story my mom has a photo of me
when i was like 12 years old we're on
vacation by the beach and i'm reading a
book on how to get your sag card are you
serious yeah i tried to get her to send
it to me before tonight so i could show
people it's just pretty funny that's
amazing
you